there have been plenty of leaks and
rumors surrounding the gtx 1180 many
rumors suggesting that the gtx 1180 will
be revealed in just two weeks while
others are still suggesting the gtx at
1184 becoming out till 2019 so which of
these religious truth and one was the
gtx 1180 actually come out
[Music]
welcome to hurry saudis so first of all
you had to look at the age of the 10
series the 10 series is already over two
years old while this is not that long of
a time period this is the longest series
that has been coming out from nvidia and
quite a while now and on top of that at
this point in this life cycle the people
who wanted the tim series most likely
already have it and people who don't
have a 10 series card right now
alright i don't want because they don't
want to buy almost Achtung at Tech and
want to bite the 11 Series or they're
scavenging for the perfect 10 series
deal as a result 10 series sales are
really low now don't get me wrong here
the GTX 10 series is a great solid
series which will last you for a long
time even if you buy it right now it's
just that a lot of people prefer to buy
something new or simply already have a
10 series card already either way Nvidia
sales are really low for the 10 series
and it just does not make sense to
continue to push the series into the
future and on top of this they already
have the technology ready for the 11
series so why push it off when it will
significantly increase their sales plus
if you look at the price of 10 series
cars right now they're astronomically
low right now you can get a GTX 1084 444
dollars which is an all-time low for
that card so why would retailers be
offering these GPUs for such a low
prices if there isn't something else
coming to take its place
so clearly they're trying to get rid of
inventory before it's too late
now some leaks and rumors are suggesting
that the GTX and lemon trees won't be
coming out till the beginning of 2019
but this really doesn't make sense
because why we Nvidia release a new
series right after the huge holiday
season of 2018 just ended now you may be
like in order to get rid of all their
excess tensors GPUs
but the thing is they're already doing
that with really little prices and I
doubt their continued to do that without
anything new for the next five months
and plus the eleventh series on top of
the ten series for the holiday season
well just boost sales even more and
considering India's sales report from
the second quarter they clearly need a
boost after the huge mining crash of
line 18 so I really do think that Nvidia
is trying to take advantage of the
holiday season of this year and they
won't skip out on it
finally GT dr6 memory production has
already begun quite a while ago and that
definitely is not just a coincidence and
definitely has a correlation with the
eleven series is launched as hey Hynix
is not gonna just sit there producing GD
r six memories for no reason
honestly I believe it the reason that
the GDD are six memory production
started so early was because the GTX
1100 series was actually planned for
July however once that huge inventory
issue came up in the video is unable to
continue with this plan and they
postponed the launch of the eleven
horror series and Jensen Wang simply
made that comment about how the leavener
is not coming for a long time
to prevent 10 series sales from going
down even more so the 1100 series has
already gotten pushed back quite a while
so I really doubt this trend is going to
continue especially with the GP wanted
production stopping way back in February
so based on all of this the eleventh
series were most likely being revealed
on August 20th
just like expected especially with all
the leaks and rumors coming out recently
and the 1180 1160 and lemon 70 will all
come out before the beginning of the
holiday season of 2018
oh yeah also the price of the 11 new
series are not going to be crazy high
there may be a small premium over the
last generation like up to $50 but it's
not giving anything too crazy but that's
just what I think what do you guys think
when do you guys think the GTX 11a is
going to come out make sure to comment
down below what you guys think because I
do it on my comments I'm curious as to
what you guys think so make sure to post
your thoughts also if you guys like
spear that make sure drop like and
consider subscribing if you'd like to
see more videos just like this one but
until then I'm Hari I'll see you guys on
the next one